anybody who comes in uh i'm
delighted that although that that uh
the prince charles and everybody is here
today to see a country that is uh i
think undergone a complete
transformation or a very very
substantial transformation uh and are
you i think i think
i think that
um
people need to keep
uh an open mind about uh the policy
those
the critics need to keep an open mind
about i think a lot of people can see
it's it's obvious merits and yeah of
course if uh
if i'm if i'm seeing the
prince tomorrow i'm of course going to
make that point
well our political editor beth rigby has
all the latest now from kigali that will
no be no doubt be on the agenda as he
has bilateral meetings he met with the
president of rwanda
paul kagame
today he visited a school this is the
first of a series of summits for boris
johnson he's out of the country for
eight days he's here in rwanda for
chogham the commonwealth heads of
government meetings when 54 heads of
state come together they're going to
talk about
trade they're also going to talk about
food security in light of the war in
ukraine he is then going on
to the g7 summit uh in bavaria in
germany before flying on
to nato in spain next week so this is a
big moment on the world stage for boris
johnson lots on the agenda clearly here
in rwanda but one big theme that is
coming out
of this meeting and will no doubt triple
uh into trickle into the others is the
issue of food security it's going to be
high on the agenda here this is about
concerns over food shortages the u.n
warning
last week that countries faced protest
riots and potential political violence
because of the surge in food prices
already happening because of covid and
fuel shortages and prices but now spike
in two because of the war in ukraine and
the effect that's having on exports food
exports
from russia and ukraine to put it in to
context ukraine grows enough food every
year to feed 400 million
people and produces 42
of the world's sunflower oil and 10
of the world's maize so food shortages
having an impact on some of the
commonwealth countries high on the
agenda here and i think it will be
something picked up at the g7 and nato
how can allies help try and get food
stuffs out of ukraine against the
backdrop of backdrop of the continued
war
with russia